le capitaine du titanic ecall en 13 ans
de carrière mario ronde ou n'a jamais
vécu une telle situation
ils sont en voie les asperges et on
profite trop vite on n'a pas de garden
hill
on va peut être récolté la moitié de la
superficie la moitié de la quantité
qu'on récolte d'une année normale
le gros point central c'est la main de
vitrac et pour arriver à terme qui est
arrivé du tout onze travailleurs
étrangers agricoles travaillent dans ces
champs il en a le double normalement la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre a de graves
conséquences faute de personnel il doit
fourche et ses terres et jeté des
milliers de livres das perche on va en
faire la plus pour ottawa offre une aide
aux producteurs mais pour mario c'est
trop peu trop tard présente mal alors on
tape on s'inscrit pour mettre des
preuves à la plus de factures format des
mois mon hôtel faut qu'ils se parlent
d'un changeait pas le temps de jouer
dans mon bureau commencé à remplir sa
part à cette incroyable ça fait mal au
coeur
même difficulté pour stéphane roy je me
sens comme un funambule avec un arrivé à
d'autres bouquets l'automne puis on se
promène sur un fil puis on se demande
son vrai rival ou de boulot 500 tombes
rip il devra lui aussi fauché ses terres
et perdra cette année au moins 30% de
ses récoltes
le gouvernement du québec offre un
incitatif financier de 100 $ par semaine
pour encourager la main d'oeuvre locale
mais c'est bien loin d'être la solution
au problème il semble pour la nécessité
de travailler là quelques-uns qui me
dis-je
j'ai pas besoin d'argent mon chapeau
pour quoi je travaille uniquement parque
vosgienne bonds us bon oeil et pour
motiver la motivation elle se retrouve
cependant chez les consommateurs de plus
en plus de québécois semblent prioriser
l'achat local
un baume pour les producteurs d'aspergés
achetez local c'est très important pour
la survie de nos entreprises ici marie
michel lauzon radio-canada à
saint-thomas dans lanaudière